quand je suis arrivé au monde en août 78
au Maroc dans un petit village je suis
né avec des complications de respiration
et le docteur du village qui à l'époque
était aussi électricien
il a été en plus c'était vétérinaire
aussi
je suis arrivé
l'hiver il dépassera pas le mois de
décembre mon papa était ici j'ai pas
drôle ça et mon papa était ici en France
il a dit non on va le soigner je suis
arrivé à l'hôpital Necker je suis resté
pendant 7 ans en 13 sorti et comme on a
coutume de dire faut pas oublier d'où on
vient moi je viens de l'hôpital Necker
et j'en suis très fier et je voilà c'est
un appel à tous ceux qui sont dans les
hôpitaux croyez en vous et je suis avec